Robots are pieces of software that can be added to a Wave like a participant...
...and in fact, can act like a participant.
They can do anything a person can do on the Wave.
They can watch the typing that's going on.
They can add other participants to the Wave.
And in fact, they can even write into the Wave.
Let me show you another extension to Wave...
...that lets you interface to a different communication system.
I'll start a new Wave and I'll add my friend, Tweety the Twitbot.
As you can see, Tweety puts in a form.
I'm gonna sign in with my Twitter username and password.
Unfortunately, it's "Twephanie".
When I submit that form, the robot notices it...
...and goes, and uses Twitter's API to get updates from the people I follow.
I can also put in my own update.
Tweety notices that and uses the Twitter APIs to update my Twitter account.
You can also use Tweety to search over the public timeline of Twitter.
Imagine, there's a phrase I care a lot about, like Google Wave.
I can enter it here...
...and Tweety will use the API to pull in Tweets with that word in them.
This way, you can use Tweety to be an alert or alarm for a phrase you care about.
I can actually leave this Wave in my account...
...and anytime there's a new match, this Wave will become active for me.
I can open it and see the new content.
Robots can be used to interface to other systems.
In this case, it was Twitter but it could be anything with an API.